Donald Trump's FEMA the Federal
Emergency Management Agency has been
caught hiding information about how
poorly things are going in Puerto Rico
on their website of course Puerto Rico
ravaged by the recent hurricanes huge
controversy over Donald Trump's handling
Trump showed up there he shot rolls of
paper towels like they were basketballs
insisted things are just going
incredibly well cheered his staff
pretend that everything was fine and
meanwhile FEMA which has a website that
documents our I guess they used to they
documented how much of Puerto Rico was
without power how much of Puerto Rico
was without drinking water all of a
sudden a few days ago that information
is gone from the website Thursday
morning the information disappears well
maybe all of the information about
Puerto Rico was gone no some facts were
still there for example the FEMA website
still very prominently said hey we've
got 14,000 federal workers on the ground
in Puerto Rico and the US Virgin Islands
that's up we've got more than 30 miles
of roadway that have been cleared up
from 20 miles earlier in the week the
numbers that looked good for FEMA stayed
very prominently visible on the website
status dot PR however kept the
information prominent and updated and it
actually looks terrible as of this
morning only 16% of the puerto rican
island has electricity eventually after
news of this broke this clearly
politically motivated hiding of
information fema put the information
back on the website but they buried it
on some internal page very difficult to
find and fema put out a statement
explaining why the data was removed they
say listen the data was always available
it had just been moved to a really
really difficult place why was it moved
no explanation about that I don't even
know how this counts as an explanation I
don't know how anybody would accept that
as an explanation from FEMA and the the
bigger issue or as big of an issue in
Puerto Rico is that the number of deaths
is drastically underreported you can be
sure that it's going to be
drastically underreported and the key
phrase I want to put sort of in your
mind is indirect deaths indirect deaths
won't be counted as hurricane related
deaths but they will be related to the
slow response and it's really tragic
right I mean I'm talking about horrible
stuff people who died or will die
because their dialysis machines won't
work because of lack of electricity for
example right an indirectly related
death to the hurricane people who will
die in a car accident because the roads
are a disaster you can imagine other
scenarios like this and by the way what
is the number of deaths right we don't
know if you google the last report is
from six days ago and it's that 34
people died wrong and BuzzFeed has been
speaking to funeral home directors and
the funeral home directors in both the
capital city of San Juan and other towns
are saying oh no no no there are
significantly more dead bodies that are
showing up here the 34 number not even
close to accounts for the actual number
of deaths and I mean just as an example
in San Juan specifically quote dozens of
bodies at just four Funeral Homes none
of which are part of that official tally
of 34 how many of those deaths are a
storm related directly or indirectly I
don't know in smaller towns who knows if
we'll ever even find out the real number
but hey hide the data in some obscure
spot on the FEMA website and it'll make
it all go away it is absolutely
disgusting and vile and the cheerleading
that is going on by the administration
as if everything is just hunky-dory and
fantastic it's it's starting to get to
the point of pathological lying and
that's really not uncharted territory
for the Trump administration the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad